so in this video I wanted to present an
alternative way to find the base to acid
ratio if you are given a pH and a pKa
this alternative does not use the
henderson-hasselbalch equation rather we
use the KA so earlier we've mentioned
the whole classic reaction in which you
have an acid dissociating into H+ and an
anion and we talked about how the KA
expression would be products over the
reactants just try to put that negative
there all over H a now what you could do
is simply move this h+ divide it you
know divide both sides by 8 h+ so that
we can get this ka over h plus equals
the conjugate base concentration over
the undissociated acid concentration so
in others this is the base 2 acid ratio
right now here we have ka and the H+
concentration so if we use our knowledge
that of the definitions here that I will
present the pH if you remember is equal
to the negative log of the H+
concentration so what is the H+
concentration equal well if we move this
negative over we get negative pH equals
the log of the H+ concentration right
and if we undo this right we take the
base 10 both sides to undo that log and
then we get the H+ concentration is
equal to 10 to the negative pH likewise
if we have PKA that's equal to the
negative log of the KA right we can do
the same thing here negative PKA equals
the log of the KA take the base 10 of
both sides and then we get the KA oops
of the concentration of the KA
excuse me so we get the KA is equal to
10 to the negative PKA right so we have
here now right is these two definitions
right this H+ concentration is equal to
10 to the negative pH and the KA is
equal to the 10 to the negative PKA
all right so notice that's what we have
here ka h plus so the K we can replace
this right with the KA is equal to 10 to
the negative PKA over each plus
concentration is 10 to the negative pH
so if we're given both the PK and the pH
we want to find the base acid ratio we
can just simply plug this in and that's
what we get as our ratio so in an
earlier problem actually in the previous
video we were told that we were told
that the pH we were John my aspartate I
believe right yeah aspartate the pKa of
the sidechain was equal to 4 and the pH
of the environment was 5 right and when
we did that we found that the base 2
acid ratio was 10 to 1 right we found at
the base 2 acid ratio was 10 to 1 right
so when we do that here
we should get so this would be 10 to the
negative PK that PK is 4 so we have 10
to the negative 4 over 10 to the
negative 5 we get then is 10 to the 1
right which is 10 over 1 so we get that
same exact answer ok so this is just a
quick overview about another way to
solve the problem in case it's way seems
to make more sense click a little bit
better I ran through that quite quickly
but that's essentially what the
henderson-hasselbalch equation does but
this is kind of just presenting it to
you in a different
so if this way is easier for you than by
all means use this way that's about it
thanks for watching